you know why I didn't take the job
because it's too small I don't care
about it it's nothing to me it's a
bacterium I travel in Worlds you can't
even imagine you can't conceive of what
I'm capable of I'm so far beyond you I'm
like a god in human clothing lighting
gold shoes from my fingertips hello and
welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Nikki Novak today is a
very big day and I'm talking very big
because we are talking about spin-off
series shows that feature or extend or
just build upon one or more aspects from
a previous or existing series and this
list highlights ones that not only had
great parent shows but also went on to
become just as great if not greater
while these titles do all share the
common trait of being a spin-off the
similarities pretty much stop there from
Warrior princesses to beer bottle
cappers to the drama surrounding live
action and animated female teenagers
this list of the best TV spin-off Series
has it all so let's do it Xena Warrior
Princess I'm gonna give you one chance
communists you'll give up now
go easy on you no please you and what
army
and battling to kick this list off is
Xena Warrior Princess this series was
developed by Sam Rainey and follows Xena
played by Lucy Lawless a mighty warrior
princess with a dark cast who is out to
redeem herself the show is a spin-off of
Hercules the Legendary Journeys where
Xena began as a recurring Nemesis with a
three-episode Arc That was supposed to
end with her death but producers became
aware of her popularity and decided to
launch another series instead so Xena
Warrior Princess began in 1995 and aired
in first run syndication lasting for six
seasons and 134 episodes the same amount
of Seasons as Hercules but with more
episodes
and while we're comparing the two it's
worth noting that Xena flew by its
predecessor in ratings and popularity by
season two it was the top rated
syndicated drama on TV and remained in
the top five for all of its six seasons
and the reason this series caught on
bigger than Hercules starts with a
titular character a strong female
protagonist which was not a common thing
on TV at the time and the strong cult
following she helped create has landed
her and the TV show and various best of
lists over the past 20 years while
helping influence the direction of the
genre on TV moving forward NBC kicked
around the idea of a reboot in 2015 but
that idea has sadly been shelled for now
but that's okay because you gotta
re-watch the original anyway while
keeping an eye out for boys star Carl
Irvin who played both Julius Caesar and
Cupid at various times during the show's
run you are so welcome for that little
tidbit Frasier you look here buddy
making sure everyone knows its name next
on this list is the sitcom Frasier the
series is a spin-off of the long-running
and wildly popular cheers it continues
the story of psychiatrist Fraser crane
played by Kelsey Grammer who moves back
to his hometown of Seattle to be a radio
show host and reconnect with his family
Frazier began four months after cheers
ended and much like his predecessor
lasted for 11 Seasons there is a Revival
on the way but more on that in a minute
initially when the time came for grammar
to start thinking about what's next
after cheers he wasn't initially
interested in continuing the Frasier
character but after a couple failed
pitches with other ideas it was decided
by the suits that a spin-off was the way
to go and grammar ultimately agreed
so angry is like a madman
look producers tried to set the shows
far from Boston as possible the location
for cheers to curb any expectations from
NBC that there would be constant guest
appearances from the Cheers cast
although other than Kirsty Allen's
Rebecca all of the surviving main cast
members from cheers did show up on
Frasier with his ex-wife Lilith played
by beami newerth getting a recurring
role well it's hard to compare any show
to a juggernaut like cheers this one
actually holds its own holds its own
beer in fact Frazier's 34 Emmys is six
better even more impressive though is
the fact that the main Fraser casts
remain unchanged for all 11 seasons and
when the series ended in 2004 grammar
had played the character for a total of
20 years tied for the most ever at the
time of course Law and Order SVU has
since changed that so maybe that's why
Frasier Revival has been greenlit and is
expected to be released on Paramount
Plus in 2023. Laverne and Shirley I tell
you you must swear you won't laugh too
loud because she's right in the bedroom
and I don't want her to hear okay all
right Laverne is afraid to drive
next on this list is the one and only or
should I say two and only Laverne and
Shirley the show is a spin-off from
Happy Days where Penny Marshall's
Laverne and Cindy Williams Shirley were
introduced as friends of The Fawns
played by Henry Winkler hey you knew I
was gonna go there both shows were
created by Gary Marshall brother of
Penny and are set in roughly the same
time period in the Vernon Shirley the
pair are roommates who work as bottle
cappers in the fictitious shots Brewery
in the late 1950s Milwaukee that is
until they moved to Burbank for the last
couple Seasons to work as a Department
Store gift wrappers a natural
progression the series ran for eight
seasons from 1976 to 1983 and while that
doesn't top the 11th season run of Happy
Days the show did climb to the top of
the rating a beating both happy days and
his other spin-off Mork and Mindy hey
what time does Tweedle downpour why why
do you care I'm tweet of them no believe
me I'm dumb
hey you're both morons now shut up what
are you talking about all right where
does it say tweedly [ __ ] and some of
what set Laverne and Shirley apart from
the others was a fresh brand of Comedy
AKA physical comedy that the actresses
brought to the screen to go along with
Golden Globe and Emmy nominations the
show's popularity spawned a merchandise
franchise and an animated spin-off yes a
spin-off of a spin-off while Laverne and
Shirley in the Army which began airing
on Saturday mornings in 1981. but if
we're really gonna talk about what put
this show in another Stratosphere we
gotta mention the theme song making our
dreams come true by Cindy Greco in a
time when Happy Days help set set the
bar high for theme songs this one went
above and beyond becoming a radio
favorite and a top 30 hit
Law and Order Special Victims Unit
please read this Reddit post
who the hell likes Blue Glacier shampoo
and why would they use a disgusting
like Katie Miller
they sell their crap you posted that on
Reddit at 9 48 pm on November 6th is
that right
created by dip wolf and marked the first
spin-off of his hit drama Law and Order
which was nearly a decade into its run
before SVU launched in the fall of 1999
and much like the original this series
occasionally pulls from the headlines of
real stories about NYPD investigations
the show which was originally titled sex
crimes before getting changed to the
more accurate and palatable Special
Victims Unit began by focusing
exclusively on the police work with
District Attorneys only stopping it
occasionally that changed in season two
when the format became more faithful to
the Law and Order way of including court
cases with each story
sbu is still going strong with over 500
episodes since 99 and even outlasting
its predecessor although law order did
return in 2022 with new episodes because
hey why not make sense of this
husband is dead
killed by my own child's hand
and my willingness to believe he was a
monster
how awful it must have been for my
husband
to know that the people he loved most
had turned on him
by the way if you're getting score at
home when it comes to Prime Time
scripted series SVU ranks fourth in the
number of episodes behind The Simpsons
Gunsmoke and classy and as if the case
for the spin-off hasn't already been
impressively stated we also gotta
mention the 91 Emmy nominations with 33
wins and counting but if you really want
to know why Law and Order Special
Victims Unit stands above the original
we got two words for you Mariska
Hargitay not only is her Olivia Benson
one of the longest running live-action
characters in the history of Primetime
TV she was the first regular cast member
on any Law and Order series to win Emmy
Award when she earned lead actress in a
drama in 2006. enough said Better Call
Saul excuse me oh please you suffer one
little setback and you're gonna let your
entire Legacy go
one little setback fine your pain is
very special what was you just stop
wallowing okay this place is all you've
got that in your hair which let's face
it clocks tick in there too so you want
to save your business you want to save
your dignity you're gonna have to fight
hey
you're a lawyer Howard
but you're a great salesman so get out
there and sell dialing up the next spot
on the list is the hit drama series
Better Call Saul this one is a spin-off
and a prequel to co-creator Vince
Gilligan's previous series Breaking Bad
which aired for Five Seasons before
ending in 2013. Better Call Saul is
mostly set in the early to mid 2000s in
Albuquerque following the earlier days
of Bob odenkirk's Saul Goodman character
we see him evolve from an Earnest lawyer
named Jimmy McGill into the egocentric
criminal defense attorney who works with
Big Time drug manufacturers Jonathan
Banks and Giancarlo Esposito also
majorly reprized their roles for
Breaking Bad with many others making
guest appearances Vince Gilligan and his
Better Call Saul co-creator Peter Gould
first discussed a spin-off with Bob
Odenkirk while filming the third season
finale of Breaking Bad and wouldn't you
know it filming for this show began just
a little over a year after that one
ended Better Call Saul premiered on AMC
in February of 2015 and ended up going
six seasons one more than Breaking Bad
If You're comparing the two which you
probably really shouldn't best of luck
in all your future endeavors go goodbye
go sorry sorry about that
and loose in the aisle somebody call an
ambulance no you don't need to
I don't need
oh hey yes an ambulance that's a good
idea
you guys have liability insurance right
Bob odenkirk's 2022 best actor Emmy
nomination marked the fifth time he was
nominated for this series and to go
along with 46 Emmy Noms overall Better
Call Saul has also received 15
writers-skilled 14 Critics Choice and
six sag Award nominations among many
other accolades and yet never one I'm
happy
Plus for the good deed award I've
decided to give out the New Mexico film
office reported that through its first
four seasons this show brought over 120
million dollars to the state now that is
an impressive spin-off stat
The Colbert rapport
yo yo yo
the satirical news comedy and talk show
features Stephen Colbert playing a
caricature a conservative cable news
pundits while lampooning current events
and the political issues of the day this
series is a spin-off of comedy Central's
The Daily Show where Colbert was a
correspondent from 1997 to 2005 and the
Rapport was created by Colbert along
with Daily Show host and producer John
Stewart the series ran four days a week
on Comedy Central from 2005 to 2014 and
now no math whiz but the internet did
tell me that they did 1447 episodes in
total dang of course The Daily Show has
been on air since 1996 and is the
longest running show in Comedy Central
with 24 Emmys and Counting I wish he
could have joined us when I had lunch
with Meryl Streep and Ecuadorian
president Rafael Correa
such a cut up
oh oh did that surprise you no O is just
what all her real friends call Opa but
the Colbert Rapport became a different
kind of animal during its time Colbert
carried his shtick over and fine-tuned
it becoming known for inventing new
words that entered popular culture like
truthiness after seeing critical and
rating success right off the bat that
shows relevance expanded beyond the
airwaves Colbert ran for president twice
gave a controversial performance at the
White House Correspondence Dinner
co-hosted a political rally and
established a million dollar raising
Super PAC beat that Jon Stewart well
speaking of which The Colbert Report was
nominated for an Emmy every year for
outstanding variety or comedy series but
lost to the Daily Show every year until
2013 ending the longest winning streak
in Emmy history whoa spin-off drama it
reminds me of Susan Lucci all over again
The Jeffersons Mr Jefferson why ah you
dressed like that because I'm gonna have
my picture taken to put in my store
window your picture you made fun of
Cunningham for doing that that's cause
you ain't as pretty as me
what you doing
what are you laughing at
what was gonna happen here I'm finally
wigged out moving on up next on this
list is The Jeffersons this spin-off
from All in the Family follows
African-American couple George and
Louise Jefferson best known as Wheezy
neighbors too Archie and Edith Bunker on
All in the Family as they moved into a
Swanky high-rise building thanks to the
success of his dry cleaning business the
show was created by Norman Lear who also
brought All in the Family to the small
screen along with about a hundred other
shows and while The Jeffersons mostly
fell into the traditional sitcom mold it
wasn't afraid to tackle more serious
issues like gun control alcoholism adult
literacy and being transgender plus it
was one of the first shows to
prominently feature a married
interracial couple yeah yeah boss I sure
hope you liked it
is it all right it's okay I freshen it
up for you
okay George is that good enough for you
well she ain't perfect yet but she's
getting there this marked the second All
in the Family spin-off after mod but
ended up becoming the longest running of
any of the shows lasting 11 Seasons to
all in the family's nine in fact it's
one of the longest running sitcoms ever
and it was one of the longest running
series with a predominantly
African-American cast until Tyler
Perry's House of Pain surpassed it by
one single episode in 2012. The
Jeffersons picked up 14 Emmy nominations
during its run nowhere near All in the
Family but respectable nonetheless and
sadly it ended in a little bit of
controversy after CBS abruptly canceled
the series without allowing for a proper
series finale
this spin-off also got its own spin-off
featuring The Jeffersons housekeeper
Florence and called checking in but it
only lasted four episodes had it been
longer it could have been our
non-existent episode with the best TV
spin-off spin-off series
Daria
[Applause]
you'll pay through the nose for that
shot Missy unless you can give me a
plausible reason for your being here I
was having too much fun at home so I
thought I'd go out and get killed by an
unstable parade float yep through the
nose next on this list of the best TV
spin-off series is the animated hit
darya this show is a spin-off of Mike
judge's Beavis and Butthead the culture
shifting MTV series that began in 1993
and has since returned a couple of times
with a total of seven years and nine
seasons on the air so far this season
follows Daria a recurring character from
the Beavis and Butthead series who is an
intelligent yet cynical high school
student created to act as a foil to the
guys and their Antics to take that one
step further MTV execs looking to raise
the female demographic of the channel
decided to give Daria her own show which
debuted in 1997 nine months before
Beavis and Butthead ended its original
run
I hate to say it but I think I enjoy
this process geez what kind of process
do they use it's a sugarless version of
the one for Ding Dongs and Ho Hos
Ding Dongs and ho-hos you're crazy I
think that's kind of why I like you I
like you too that's what's really crazy
in the first episode of Daria she and
her family moved from the BNB setting of
Highland to the equally fictional town
of Lawndale introducing Daria's parents
younger sister and best friend as major
characters and from there other than a
brief mention of Highland this series
did not contain any other references to
Beavis and Butthead or feature any of
their characters that could be because
other than allowing the character to be
spun off Mike Judge was a little bit
busy with King of the Hill and had no
real involvement in Daria but the
explanation from the creators was that
Beavis and Butthead were very strong
characters with loyal fans and a
specific type of humor so they wouldn't
have to quite fit but also makes sense
Daria ran for Five Seasons and also
produced a couple of made for TV movies
one of which features several songs by
the Foo Fighters and Dave Grohl as a
guest voice along with celebs like
Carson Daly and Biff naked MTV announced
a spin-off Series in 2019 called Daria
and Jody which was later switched to an
animated TV movie for Comedy Central and
given the title of just Jody Tracy Ellis
Ross is voicing the titular character
and executive producing The Facts of
Life Miss climber says if I can just
complete this chemistry experiment
there's a b-plus floating out there for
me keep it flown for a minute I'm busy
chemistry is the one [ __ ] in my
Scholastic armor I need your special
attention
I told you I'd help you Blair but right
now I'm trying to get down a few of my
private inner adult feelings while
they're still playing on my soul taking
the good and putting into this list next
is The Facts of Life this series was a
spin-off of different strokes and
followed that shows housekeeper Ed
mcgarrett played by Charlotte Ray as she
became the house mother at an all-girls
private school in New York there she
cared for kids like the spoiled rich
girl Blair paid by Lisa welchel the
gossipy 2D played by Kim Fields and the
impressionable Natalie played by Mindy
Cohn the pilot for Facts of Life first
aired as the season one finale of
different strokes and the two universes
remained connected Mr Drummond and
Arnold from Different Strokes made a few
guest appearances while Tudy returned
the favor and appeared on their show
did struggle initially during its first
season after being given a tough Friday
night time slot but after a move to
Wednesday for season two The Facts of
Life quickly became the fourth highest
rated TV show that year behind Little
House in the prairie Different Strokes
and ships the series never looked back
after that as it became one of the
longest running sitcoms of the 80s
lasting for nine seasons one longer than
Different Strokes and releasing three
made for TV movies this leg is still
wobbly I know what it needs Elmers
what's that Elmer's it's a glue
could never do and even though the theme
songs for both shows involved Alan
Thicke as a composer or a performer it's
The Facts of Life song that will be
stuck in your head for the rest of the
day as soon as you hear the words
take the good you take the bad you take
them both and there you have The Facts
of Life and that's our list of the best
TV spin-offs as always there was too
many other great shows to put on our
list so stay tuned for more RT essential
episodes to find out if your picks make
a list I'm your host Nikki Novak and
we'll see you on the next one bye
[Music]